y
[Música]
los 20 acusados por los atentados
terroristas de parís en 2015 fueron
condenados a mayor sentencia fue para
sala abdeslam el único sobreviviente de
la unidad yihadista quien pagara cadena
perpetua
en mexico le dispararon y mataron al
periodista antonio de la cruz en el
ataque hirieron a su hija es el
reportero número 12 que asesinan en el
país en lo que va del año la fiscalía
general ya abrió una investigación
el gobierno de texas en eeuu le pidió al
presidente joe biden que endurezca las
medidas migratorias y retomé las
políticas de donald font entretanto los
tres emigrantes hallados con vida en el
interior de un trailer siguen delicados
de salud otras 53 personas fallecieron
en el 20
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
estar con ustedes
diez meses tuvieron que esperar los
familiares de las víctimas los
sobrevivientes y en general la sociedad
francesa para oír el veredicto contra
saleh abdeslam a cadena perpetua sin
derecho a libertad condicional la
justicia francesa también condenó a las
otras 19 personas que colaboraron con
los ataques de esa noche del 13 de
noviembre de 2015
que dejaron 130 muertos el veredicto
marca un antes y un después en la
historia de francia al haber generado un
debate sobre la lucha contra el
terrorismo la seguridad y la migración
en el país
la periodista de france 24 erika
olavarría nos dio previamente más
detalles desde la capital francesa
cadena perpetua irreductible la corte
especial que juzgaba los atentados del
13 de noviembre ha confirmado esta noche
la pena que había solicitado el
ministerio público en contra de sal
abdeslam el único sobreviviente de los
comandos del 13 de noviembre también
confirmó la cadena perpetua pero con un
periodo de seguridad o de pena obligada
de 22 años para mohamed a brin y el
amigo de infancia de sala abre slam y
conocido como el hombre del sombrero que
participó también en los atentados de
bruselas de marzo del 2016 es parte de
esta gran sentencia de 120 páginas en la
que también tres cadenas perpetuas se
dudaron a penas de presidio de 30 años
para tres de los miembros de la célula
yihadista sino las pequeñas manos
aquellos sujetos que ayudaron a salvar
de la a viajar entre parís y bruselas la
noche del 13 de noviembre vieron también
reducida sus penas ellos comparecían en
libertad y por lo tanto podrán seguirlo
hasta el final de esta condena con esta
con este veredicto se cierra un momento
histórico en parís y en francia esos
atentados que dejaron 130 muertos pero
sobre todo una gran herida a la sociedad
que todavía no se cerraba con varios de
los familiares de víctimas que pudimos
hablar algunos de ellos se muestran
satisfechos otros no pues querían que
todas las cadenas perpetuas se
cumplieran sin embargo varios abogados
con los que conversamos también nos
decían que les parece que el caso de
salas de slam y mohamed a britney es un
símbolo la cadena perpetua no es una
pena que suele usarse o cumplirse
generalmente se equipara una pena de
presidio de 30 años y que por lo tanto
en este caso para ello se ha hecho
justicia
de parís nos vamos a madrid en el
segundo día de la cumbre de la otan los
países integrantes de la alianza
estuvieron de acuerdo en considerar que
en la actualidad rusia es la mayor
amenaza para occidente la alianza
también indicó que dará más apoyo a
ucrania a través de una renovación de
las fuerzas armadas de ese país y
también afirmó que reforzará la
presencia militar en las naciones del
este de europa que están cerca del
territorio ruso como los estados
bálticos son noruega polonia entre otros
[Aplausos]
se trata de un delicado equilibrio para
los dirigentes de la otan a dejar que
sus miembros armen a ucrania sin
provocar un enfrentamiento directo con
una rusia que cuenta con armas nucleares
selenski y lleva meses pidiendo el apoyo
de las democracias occidentales una
llamada a la que los líderes mundiales
decidieron responder en la cumbre de la
otan en madrid y nuestra respuesta fue
si estamos preparados porque están
luchando por su independencia pero
también están luchando por valores que
son importantes para el auto
para pasar de las palabras a los hechos
eeuu refuerza su posición militar en
europa del este como primera fuerza
militar de la otan 100.000 tropas
estadounidenses están actualmente
estacionadas en europa y se prevé que
aumenten especialmente en el este vaivén
también desplegará más aeronaves en
reino unido- y aumentará su flota naval
en españa'
creo que esta cumbre es la oportunidad
de coordinar nuestros esfuerzos para
garantizar la seguridad de nuestro
espacio
en otro espacio otros países están
siguiendo el ejemplo de eeuu canadá se
comprometió a enviar tropas a letonia
noruega también dijo que donaría tres
sistemas de cohetes de lanzamiento
múltiple a ucrania la otan en su
conjunto tiene previsto multiplicar por
siete el número de tropas en alerta
máxima pasando de 40 mil a 300 mil
también abordaron cuestiones que van más
allá de las fronteras de europa en
particular el fortalecimiento de la
región del indo pacífico así como
abordar los desafíos de china y las
amenazas del programa nuclear de corea
del norte
otra de las noticias sobre la otan es
que invitó formalmente a suecia y a
finlandia para ser parte de la alianza
poco tiempo después rusia reaccionó
diciendo que esto no es un problema a
menos que se acerquen militarmente a su
frontera a pesar de la postura del
kremlin algunos funcionarios consideran
que las tensiones en la región
aumentarán marina sardiña nos amplia
una noticia recibida con frialdad moscú
aseguró que no ve como un problema la
adhesión de finlandia y suecia a la otan
una solicitud formal ya en trámite con
el objetivo de obtener garantías en
materia de seguridad adicionales
incentivadas por la invasión del kremlin
de ucrania el pasado 24 de febrero
no tenemos disputas territoriales con
ellos no hay nada que nos pueda
preocupar en términos de que finlandia y
suecia se conviertan en miembros de la
otan
pero unos funcionarios rusos aseguraron
que las nuevas merecías a la alianza del
atlántico norte aumentarán las tensiones
en la región al ser un esfuerzo
desestabilizador como señaló el vice
canciller ruso serguéi riabkov y el
mandatario ruso vladimir putin también
advirtió que respondería por la vía
militar si estas naciones acogen tropas
e infraestructuras de la otan en su
territorio y es que finlandia comparte
1300 kilómetros de frontera con la
federación rusa
brasileña ahora si desplieguen las
tropas y la infraestructura de la otan
nos veremos obligados a responder de la
misma para crear las mismas amenazas y
cerca
y
todo iba bien entre nosotros pero ahora
habrá atención es seguro que las habrá
esto es obvio e inevitable repito si hay
una amenaza para nosotros como cruz
hasta el momento putin había criticado
las intenciones de finlandia y suecia
acusando a la alianza de tener
ambiciones imperiales mientras que la
otan dejó claro que no busca la
confrontación con moscú
en noticias de ucrania amnistía
internacional publicó un informe en el
que afirma que el ataque contra el
teatro en mariupol fue un claro crimen
de guerra este bombardeo ocurrió el 16
de marzo y fue uno de los primeros que
se conocieron internacionalmente contra
instalaciones civiles después de veces
de investigación el organismo sostiene
que aeronaves rusas lanzaron dos bombas
de 500 kilos según la organización los
rusos atacaron deliberadamente el lugar
a pesar de que sabían que allí se
refugiaban civiles
el primer ministro de israel naftalí
bennett afirmó que no aspirará a una
reelección en los próximos comicios y es
que el parlamento está a punto de
disolverse luego de que bennett
promoviera el cambio legislativo tras
las luchas internas que le impidieron
gobernar esta sería la quinta elección
en menos de cuatro años nuestro
corresponsal en jerusalén federico
cuevas de arena nos explica qué está
ocurriendo
con apenas poco más de un año en el
cargo de primer ministro de israel
naftalí bennett anunció que no buscará
su reelección y que se alejara de la
función pública cuando se forme el nuevo
gobierno aunque no se trata de algo
definitivo porque en sus palabras servir
a israel es su destino además se
confirmó que su partido político ya mina
será liderado por el jaked actual
ministro de interior en una figura del
ala más dura de esta formación
derechista que se ha mostrado dispuesta
a formar un gobierno con el ex primer
ministro benjamin netanyahu y que podría
convertirse en una jugadora clave en el
futuro político israelí y aunque benítez
dio su mensaje de despedida deberá
permanecer en el cargo por al menos un
día más luego de que la que knesset el
parlamento israelí fallara en su
objetivo de disolverse antes de la
medianoche del miércoles tras una
jornada de intensos idas y vueltas a los
legisladores aplazaron la resolución
para el jueves por la mañana también
deberán fijar la fecha de las nuevas
elecciones las quintas en tres años y
medio algo en lo que tampoco hay acuerdo
la oposición prefiere que sean el 25 de
octubre y el oficialismo el primero de
noviembre
de los desencuentros están dos proyectos
de que la coalición considera clave
aprobar antes de la disolución del
parlamento 1 allanaría el camino para
que los israelíes tengan una extensión
de visados para viajar a eeuu y el otro
a avanzar y a un sistema de metro para
tel aviv y sus alrededores pero ambos
proyectos están estancados entre una
oposición que no quiere entregar
victorias al gobierno antes de las
elecciones y los propios algunos
partidos de la formación de gobierno que
buscan ganar tiempo y forzar la
aprobación de estos proyectos en este
escenario y sin la que necesiten logra
disolverse el jueves yair lapid el
actual ministro de exteriores- asumirá
de manera formal como primer ministro
interino de israel en los primeros
minutos del viernes
vamos a américa el gobierno del estado
de texas en eeuu le pidió al presidente
joe biden que endurezca las medidas
migratorias y que retomar las políticas
que en su momento fueron impuestas
durante la administración de donald
trump entretanto sigue siendo crítica la
situación de salud de 13 de los
migrantes que sobrevivieron encontrados
en el interior de un trailer allí fueron
hallados sin vida otras 53 personas
todos estaban en condiciones de
hacinamiento de otra parte del gobierno
mexicano elevó la cifra de sus
connacionales fallecidos a 27
la familia de javier flórez pide ayuda
para encontrarlo él podría ser uno de
los migrantes mexicanos que viajaban en
el camión de contrabando en cuyo
interior fallecieron decenas de personas
en busca de mejor vida como les vuelvo a
repetir esto que no que nos ayuden por
localizarlo pues ya el dijera lo que no
es top flores y su primo josé luís
vázquez habían partido rumbo a eeuu
vázquez es uno de los sobrevivientes se
encuentra en un hospital de texas tras
sufrir deshidratación severa pero aún no
hay constancia del paradero de javier ni
si realmente iba en el camión según el
gobierno mexicano al menos 27 de los
fallecidos son mexicanos y los
sobrevivientes están en situación
crítica en general el personal médico de
los hospitales
insisto en general ha indicado que los
heridos están en estado crítico con
fallas neurológicas renales y hepáticas
y con hemorragias internas en medio de
este contexto el gobernador de texas
pidió al presidente joe biden retornar a
la estricta política migratoria de
donald trump incluyendo la construcción
del polémico muro fronterizo
y todo lo que hemos hecho hasta ahora no
habría sido necesario si el presidente
de bailén hubiera mantenido el plan de
seguridad fronteriza que había
implementado el expresidente de manchar
las políticas migratorias de trump
fueron criticadas por no atacar los
problemas de raíz de la migración como
la pobreza o la violencia en los países
de origen mientras la actual
administración enfrenta una mayor
presión por la gestión de la frontera
redoblada de cara a las elecciones de
medio término de noviembre baiden ha
prometido combatir en bandas de tráfico
de personas y su gobierno busca
estrategias regionales para frenar los
flujos migratorios
en mexico mataron al periodista antonio
de la cruz el reportero número 12 que
asesinan en lo que va del año en el país
según la sociedad interamericana de
prensa le dispararon cuando salía de su
casa en ciudad victoria en el noreste
mexicano e hirieron a su hija de la cruz
trabajaba en expreso victoria
previamente hablamos con el director
editorial del medio miguel domínguez
quien nos explicó si sirve o no que sea
la fiscalía general y no el estado la
que investigue el crimen
bueno nosotros esperaríamos que funcione
en teoría es una fiscal y fiscalía que
está especializada en los delitos contra
la libertad de expresión
desafortunadamente también hay que decir
y ustedes pueden saber méxico atraviesa
por una crisis grave en términos de
violencia contra el periodismo en la que
la impunidad desafortunadamente sí es
una constante y aquí mismo en tamaulipas
ha habido muchos asesinatos de
compañeros que han quedado impunes
nuestra exigencia es muy clara que sea
la fiscalía estatal o la fiscalía
federal pero que este crimen se
esclarezca que se dé con responsables y
que se les castigue
nuevo estado de excepción en ecuador el
presidente guillermo lasso decretó la
medida para cuatro provincias
imbabura y sucumbíos y orellana durante
30 días en esas regiones se restringen
los derechos a la libertad de asociación
y reunión y habrá un toque de queda
nocturno es la tercera vez que el
presidente decreta decepción desde que
comenzaron las protestas lideradas por
los indígenas hace tan solo cuatro días
el presidente levantó la medida y ahora
en el día 17 de protestas la reanuda
en eeuu uno de los nueve jueces de la
corte suprema de justicia se jubilará
oficialmente mañana jueves se trata del
liberal stephen breyer quien sirvió a la
corte desde 1994 sin embargo su retiro
no cambia la tendencia política del
máximo órgano judicial pues en su
reemplazo llega la jueza que está
librando jackson designada por el
presidente demócrata joe biden así se
mantienen los seis jueces conservadores
y los tres progresistas
así llegamos al final de las noticias
los invitamos a que sigan conectados con
france24 y con france24 punto com nos
vemos en minutos
[Música]